so john how has the role of the
presidency changed over the
the last several hundreds of years it's
changed dramatically when
first of all when the founders created
the presidency they left it kind of
loose they weren't exactly very specific
about what a president would do and they
realize that the first president george
washington and this is why he was so
important was a man of virtue and that
he in his behavior would set the
precedence for the next president after
him that means the job is basically
handed off by tradition from president
to president but that and the reason why
they didn't know what a president should
do is that there wasn't a notion of a
there wasn't a precedent for being a
president that's right they knew what
they didn't want they didn't want two
things they didn't want a king they just
got rid of one of those they didn't want
a king and they also didn't want
somebody who's whipped around by mob
rule they didn't so they those were the
two things they were trying to get
between but a president has a lot of
room to move in between the two of them
and they thought well put it in the
hands of a virtuous american george
washington a good first virtuous
american and that person through the
through their virtue and character would
stay in the right place would not become
a king and would not give over to the
mob but it also meant that it relied on
the character of the person in the
presidency and so each president in
subsequent years has has taken shape in
the presidency both by what was
determined by their predecessors but
also but by what they could do in the
job and what's happened is a job that
started out very weak in the american
system has now become one where some
people think of all even the entire of
american government as the president and
that's not what the founders wanted but
how does that evolve because obviously
the constitution
talks about the powers of the president
so so how does it change so much over
time what happened was when they
originally created the presidency there
was a debate and the debate was we need
somebody who can move quickly we can't
always be calling them into congress
because of course when america was
started it used to take several months
or sometimes it would take weeks to get
on a horse and get to washington so we
need an executive who can move quickly
well what happened was and in various
wars america needed to move quickly and
they needed one person to act on behalf
of the entire union well there's only
one person who can do that but as people
wanted quick action they handed over
more power to the president congress
which used to fight with the president a
lot during the second world war and then
on into our present day has given up a
lot of its power to the president one of
the key ones being the power to make war
presidents can now go and make war well
that's not the original way it was
arranged and and they've done it because
there is a hunger in the country for
quick action but the problem and
challenge of that is if you invest
somebody in with power to do things
quickly in an emergency they hold on to
that power and they don't let it go and
that means that they start doing things
when it's not an emergency that is then
not vetted by the american system and
that system has both the judiciary and
the legislative which are meant to hold
back an a president who's trying to act
too quickly and do too much and just to
go on this notion of making war as an
example
there's clear powers that you know
congress has to approve a war has the
power of the purse
so how did this happen is it they just
do that as a ritual now well it
basically there are times and congress
tries and makes attempts to try to pull
power back from the president the only
times they've been successful after the
second world war is really after
watergate
the view was that the president had
gotten too powerful that president nixon
who left office had abused the office
and so congress tried to pull some power
back but again
political parties which are now very
close to uh the president it used to be
that political parties were not so
powerful if i'm a republican in congress
and i want my republican president to do
well i'm going to give him the power he
wants because we're connected in the old
days if the president in the office was
my of my party well that's nice but i've
got my own views and i'm in congress and
i'm going to do what i want and so
essentially a lot of these powers that
have gone to the president have been
handed over to him not with a ceremony
but just by lack of of a fight
by members of congress in withdrawing
from their traditional role as the
founders wanted it as the key actor in
american government that's no longer
case in america today the president is
the key actor and then every time that
happens the next president for the next
several presidents wait that
you allowed that to happen to that that
person i should have that power that's
exactly right the it's almost like the
powers convey to the new president like
the furniture in the oval office and so
they think well this this chair is
pretty comfortable i'm not going to get
rid of that and sit in the old you know
uncomfortable wooden chair i want the
all the plush trappings and here's
another reason american politics has
created a situation and television has
made this so much worse where people run
for office promising the sun the moon
and the stars so they say i can donald
trump when he was running said i alone
can fix it that is not the way the
country was originally founded that one
person could fix or unfix things it was
supposed to be a country with
representatives of the entire country
but politics has created a system where
whether it's a republican or democrat
they run by saying i can do anything
well that means when you get in the
office you want those quick powers that
allow you to keep those campaign
promises and those quick powers are only
quick if congress and the courts aren't
in the way so politics and the way you
run for office makes presidents want to
have every possible power at their
disposal